I always thought that maybe a wedding
would be the incentive I needed to lose
weight so when I got engaged I decided
to start looking into it but after I did
a little research it quickly became
clear that the best diet was actually no
diet at all because it turns out dieting
can make you gain weight yeah diets have
been around for hundreds of years and so
you might think well it's time tested
hundreds of years we ought to trust it
but you would be wrong you'd be very so
here's the science behind by dieting can
make you gain weight body weight is
regulated by the brain which is often
resistant to extreme diet based weight
loss so when you're on a diet
sure initially you might lose weight but
likely you're gonna gain it back because
your body's gonna make you the hormone
leptin plays an important role in our
eating habits
this hormone combats our attempts at
weight loss by signaling hunger
basically you scared your body because
you starved it and so your body is like
okay [ __ ] I'm gonna start storing up
fat so if you do this to me again I'm
gonna have some fat storage to be able
to deal with that starvation this is
called the classic starvation response
the brain responds to a loss of fat by
of increasing your hunger levels so now
you're more hungry and you may eat more
food so if you're dieting you are far
more vulnerable to binge eating dieting
can be stressful in itself and stress
hormones are linked to weight gain
especially in the belly area just so you
can understand how silly diets are I
think it's best to look back on the
diving fads of yesteryear the creator of
graham crackers introduced a high-fiber
diet in the 1830s we all know what
happened obviously camping became big we
started using s'mores graham crackers
aren't that healthy when you put
chocolate marshmallow on them but they
are there was William Banton's low carb
diet from 1863 in 1903 it was popular
for people to chew food 32 times in
order to lose weight and digest food
better I guess there's a lot more things
you could do it'll lose those calories
and just sitting and chewing the
cigarette diet debuted in 1925 and we
all know how that went
yeah cigarettes not so healthy the
grapefruit diet debuted in 1930 it was
popularized in Hollywood the idea behind
the grapefruit diet was that if you need
a grapefruit with every meal you gotta
lose weight I mean I love grapefruits
but does anyone love grapefruit that
much a grapefruit every meal that's too
much great in 1934 the United Fruit
Company began pushing the banana and
skim milk diet so you see the pattern
here people are trying to sell you
things and they're trying to sell you it
by telling you you're gonna lose weight
with it this is a pattern that repeats
throughout time on the Sleeping Beauty
diet which debuted in 1976 people were
sedated for days in order to lose weight
like Sleeping Beauty had an excuse there
was a curse put on her but you just
cursed yourself
well maybe society cursed you into
thinking you needed to lose weight by
doing the Sleeping Beauty diet the
caveman diet came out 1985 and that has
morphed into what we know today as the
Paleo diet where you just eat a bunch of
meat for some reason the trendy diets of
today are the whole 30-day paleo diet
and the keto diet Christine Clark PhD
ardian she cautions against sides that
prohibit certain food groups which if
you've ever tried a diet is like most of
all diets dieters who avoid specific
food groups lose out in the nutrients
that are in those food groups the keto
diet is a high fat low carb diet which
could result in inadequate levels of
antioxidants fiber and vitamins the
whole thirty is an extremely restrictive
diet you have to eliminate dairy beans
grains sugar alcohol the diets
restrictive 'no scan make it
unsustainable if you're dieting and
you're following an unsustainable diet
you're gonna fall back to bad habits our
society is obsessed with skinniness for
no reason Eenie has not always been the
ideal body type until the 1900s curvy
women were the ideal beauty standard in
the US and Europe there was singer
actress Lillian Russell who would be
considered heavyset by today's standard
she was the ideal beauty in the late
19th century during the turn of the
century the Gibson girls set another
body standard for women the Gibson girls
were simultaneously curving fragile they
have been waist
thanks to corsets and large breasts so
that was also probably a crazy body type
to try to emulate in the 1940s and 50s
advertisers capitalized on the idea that
women who were skinny were unattractive
to men these are real ads that were
targeted at women to try to make them
gain weight which is just something
that's completely unheard of today these
ads basically reinforce the idea that to
find love thin women have to gain weight
after World War 2 and into the 1960s we
had Marilyn Monroe who had a very full
figure and was considered the ideal
beauty at the time in the 1960s
that's when thinness started to come
into vogue first with Twiggy and Audrey
Hepburn then in the 1990s ultra thin
heroin-chic who's popularized by models
like Kate Moss basically beauty
standards change all the time and
currently being a little skinny thing is
very unrealistic for most people you can
be healthy when you're slightly
overweight according to society
standards you know all these crazy fad
diets eat healthy exercise sleep watch
your stress levels and be happy in your
body because your body's perfect the way
it is and honestly trying to change it
might just be worse in the long run